wouldn't be grossing life lately it's
been two years now but yeah it's
definitely a big adventurous pose the
same I'll would like that not many 21
year olds has been on but oh oh yeah ah
I'm in contact with a fair few of them
like Liam the twins IMA see bae janelle
sort of thing like so young pin scope
contact the ones i was making friends
with are they mar that's called
spreading the patrons I he's been very
cold and my was embarrassing him a
mankini so sorry people market and I
gave me in a boa style costume but yeah
I think it's pretty close come back to
me
ok now I'm something big problems laugh
about it like smart weird you sort of
get used are people at Big Brother
gather that sort of a roller coaster of
things I think that last a year so I got
blog at the moment for the day one and
hate well Bobby WLAN calm sorry get on
it has been pickpocketed
good career move I personally would I
don't see be probably something to do
for a career seeds of life experience I
know it sounds really cheesy but yeah I
want in there for a life experience but
the way actually is just like there's so
much more to it in fact I personally
think you won't find Duncan Big Brother
Gump your brother each time ago only
really TV show really be famous thing
that I only get at Adam there's
something else if you want to experience
and you probably know I'm cursive Denver
for are doing I didn't feel I just
didn't ever say how do we know I've got
people i was on the campus through early
so I was very shocked and I was very
happy and to this day every day moving
when I like to thank you letting movie
bro inflate first of all gustaria
bezanson
the kitten is having and I'm not kissing
tell voiceover I'm a gentleman a lots
been climbing right thank you though